story in five
[Applause]
words five words Oprah's list of
favorite things so Oprah released her
annual list of favorite things and as
usual there are lots of expensive stuff
$1,000 Pizza Oven
$590 drip coffee maker
$80 of luxury
salt sadly no proposal from
stemman cat do you think she went over
this first to make sure it wasn't too
extravagant you're missing the best one
what what okay it is a little journal
and it's called I'm dead now what
important information my my belongings
business Affairs and
wishes hand this to someone at Christmas
I dare
you Holly Jolly is over after
that Oprah is actually suggesting that
EIC you're like what what do you say
like made made me think of
you probably not going to be alive much
longer Merry Christmas Oprah if she did
go over this she is a sick yeah and now
I like
her yeah it's probably a gift you won't
have time left to return I like so hey
you're probably you don't got here I'm
getting you this cuz I don't know how
many more of these you got left grandma
like
what Tyrus so you got salt you got
cheese you got
pizza I'm going to stop you there
yes uh I treat this like the list I get
from my kids they send me emails cuz
they know when I laugh in their face it
hurts anyone who wants a $1,000 Pizza
Oven you're going to get what cat picked
out like that's the greatest gift you
can give somebody because you can't
return it because returning it oh you
think you're Immortal you think you're
better than us like get your fairs in
order that's the great you stole the
show they wanted me to talk about a dog
towel that it's towels a towel um great
job that's the best gift ever and Oprah
has never read this just like I don't
read the list for my kids s me you know
Michael your list contains a can of
beans used blanket and a pillow found in
a garbage can yes and a stick with a
bandana full of my belongings that's all
I want that's all you want that's all I
want Santa yeah uh I looked at this list
and you know what wasn't else wasn't on
there uh anything about Maui right at
one point in time she and the rock made
that video to try to help out everybody
who was hurt by the fire and then and
then that was just quickly discarded
she's like okay that didn't work who
wants slippers you want slippers you get
a pair of slippers you're all getting
slippers do you think she might she
might have given some money and not
talked about it I do that a lot you
never hear about my charity cuz I won't
tell you no one's ever heard of no one's
ever heard about my charity I like to
keep it under
wraps yeah yeah just a humble guy so
humble sometimes so Under Wraps I don't
even write the check yes it's just it's
just the thought yes which which
thoughts and prayers from Greg gut yes
right which appears to be what like what
Oprah is doing for ma it seems like she
and the Rock just did that one video and
like really the people of Maui how
there's they got screwed talking about I
anticipate a letter to the show saying
uh the rock donated $20 trillion to the
fund and then you're going to have to
apologize I will say I'm sorry
immediately it's like this thing and
Maui happened and then like still
talking about cuz everyone just quickly
moved on that's a good point too that is
a good point it is a story that kind of
like just faded so basically what you're
hoping is at least she would left them
the pizza oven yeah right Ashley save
this segment I
can't I had the same thoughts that
Michael did when I saw this list and I
saw $95 cookies on here I was like this
is ex why I hate this woman what
happened to the children in Maui she was
supposed to help could you imagine being
one of the people in Maui who was
victimized by this and this woman's
going going and curating a list of $95
cookies for the bis SE she does this I I
just can't wrap my head around how
insufferable she is yeah something to
snack on as you March through $95 for
cookies what is I didn't see the it was
the issue was she was buying up all the
land and doing charity like send money
while I buy it up she was asking for
small dollar donations instead of doing
something herself she had Cookie list to
curing oh Greg I think you sent millions
of dollars yeah he sent millions of
thoughts and
prayers see that way you don't get
cheated you don't get cheated out of
those Charities if you just think about
it smart coming up with viewer mail up
the Wazoo it's a segment just for
you miss hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else